hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live your
best believe life and get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only grant cardone
enjoy
[Music]
you guys are just getting started
you're not gonna start right here
you're gonna start down there okay
probably in another city another town i
grew up in lake charles louisiana no
money raised by a single mother i was in
debt at 25 years old the first thing
that i had to do in my life was not
learn a new skill
first thing i had to do to get my life
moving in the right direction was
self-development
it is vital it was vital for me that i
improved myself and i could start
depending upon me i had to show up every
day with some rituals some disciplines
and start getting myself to trust me not
trust others but trust myself to do the
right thing every day one of the things
that i started doing was beating the sun
up every morning
i'm gonna beat that sun up every morning
so that i have the discipline and the
control of over my life
so i knew hey before that thing pops i'm
gonna pop i'm gonna get out of bed
depend on myself get up at the same time
every day and for me that time
regardless of where i was was beat that
sun up no matter where i am i'm gonna
beat that thing up so it gives me a
sense of control over my own life second
thing i had to start cleaning up my life
and my friends and my environment
when i was younger between 15 and 25 i
was doing crazy stuff in my life
wasting my weekends i had the same
weekends or for the week
i was drinking
fooling around with a bunch of bad
things bad people
making poor choices
at 25 years old i cleaned it all up quit
going to those places quit using those
things
quit hanging out with people that did
not have ethics and discipline in their
life that weren't committed to the same
things that i was
i wanted to build something in my life i
wanted to become someone and to do that
to become someone in the eyes of the
world
the first thing i had to do was become
someone i could depend on
so put some things together three or
four things you can do every day to
start the day
kick-start your day get going in your
day to give you a sense of respect for
yourself accomplishment for yourself
look just beating that sun up every
morning gives me the sense of
accomplishment that i did what i said
said i was gonna do that i woke up when
i said i would wake up and i start
building respect for myself start
believing in myself so that i can go out
into the world and maybe maybe maybe
today
maybe today when i go into this meeting
that i'm dressed for maybe they'll
believe in me as much as i believe in me
and that'll show up in a contract a deal
maybe even some money it's not about
getting the right answer it's about
being able to use the information in the
right situation
and so you have to go into a situation
knowing something's going to be stable
particularly in an environment where
there's a lot of variables and we live
in an environment right now with a lot
of variables with covid the mask the
election coming
who knows there's a million different
things going on out there you cannot you
cannot add
another variable to that many variables
so the thing that you need to do is you
have to be the stable
person
in an environment where there's a lot of
craziness going on i had so many people
tell me well it depends it depends on
the situation no
you you need to be the same person every
time
regardless of the situation
because if you try to change to every if
you try that's the problem with this
whole adapting thing
if you're going to adapt to every
situation that happens in life you'll
never become anything
because you'll just be a chameleon one
second and then a tiger the next second
and then a kitty cat the next second and
then
road kill the next
you'll just become whatever is going on
in the environment and you'll never
become strong the strong you you should
be and and that this disparity in
america particularly in america and
around the world the disparity between
the the people that have something and
everybody else is getting bigger and
bigger
if you don't like the way that is
if you don't like the way that game's
working out you need to improve your
skill set so that you can go get yours
for you and your family because it's out
there
i'm just telling you the the
opportunities out there is whether you
want to open your eyes be conscious the
whole time go look at it and figure out
how do you get your share of the of the
of the american dream one people should
be invested in the beginning and just in
themselves every chance you get to to go
to something that help could possibly
help you
has a if it has a one percent chance of
even adding to the value you have in
your spend the money
don't sit on money money's useless
so
if you have five thousand dollars left
in your account i would spend the whole
5 000 on yourself
when you spend money on yourself you're
gonna start getting better at whatever
you're doing
if you just keep doing it if you keep
spending it just because you spent it
once and it didn't work go do it again
and then again and then again
that that has been one thing in my life
like if you ask me hey what's one thing
i always invested me first
not the business not the business not
the real estate me
my condition how am i doing am i around
the right people am i listening like i
don't care what it is dinner lunch
charities i just go to anything anything
where i think there's other people doing
well
like i just want to hear somebody say
something that just inspires me you know
the 10x rule is based on look your the
goals
people are setting
are too small you know i want to get a
good job
i want to get married i want to be happy
the goals are wrong
and i hate to tell somebody their goals
are wrong but i'm just i don't know that
your goals are wrong you know i know
that
my goals have always been too small
everything i have done in my life
has not been
i have underestimated what i could do
every time i've gotten to where i got i
was like dang dude i could've that
wasn't even that hard
like it wasn't even that difficult and
it got easier as i got rid of the people
that said i couldn't do it
mostly it wasn't really people saying i
couldn't do it it was mostly people
saying dude but why do you need to
they were questioning why i need to
right so if your kid decides man he
wants to be
he don't want to be an astronaut he's
like
i don't want to be an astronaut dude
i want to be the guy that creates the
company
that sends
millions of people to another planet
see he's like why would i want to be the
pilot he's just another worker i want to
be i want to be the elon musk that
figured it out right so so and and
you'll be like man just be happy to be
an astronaut right but but he's got a
bigger dream and and we should all
that's the first thing i would tell
people look whatever you think
your dream is
one you've got to add money you got it
people people are having goals and
dreams about money you know there's all
these quotes on the internet a goal
without a date
is merely a wish that will never happen
whatever dude a goal without money
attached to it okay
is something that will never be
accomplished because there is no goal on
this planet that doesn't require money
including happy
to be happy
you need money
and and
your audience is i'd love to see their
comments like you cannot be happy
without money the only way you can be
happy and broke is to be insane yeah
because the only and insane person would
say yeah dude we're all good
i don't know where food's coming from
tonight but i'm happy that means well i
don't know where you how you're paying
for your drugs
because you can't be happy knowing i
can't pay for the next meal it's just
it's it's mentally impossible just
because you're great doesn't mean you
don't want money in fact the greater you
are the more money you're going to want
so if you want great people
i hear companies always talk about i
can't find great people because you
don't pay them anything man
right so like if i if i give you if i
offer you 700 grand right now can you
swim
yeah
you any good i'm okay yeah so if i offer
you 700 grand right now say hey dude you
got to go swimming after that boat you
got to catch it
like you're not going to worry about how
how cold the water is the water's
probably freezing ass cold right you're
gonna you're gonna if you're money
motivated
okay you're going to fly in there but
but let's say i put 700 grand out there
and say whoever gets to the boat first
exactly
will what trade exactly what would you
do it would you do it probably i think
anyone in there anyone in the world
would do it i don't know unless you're a
billionaire and you're like yeah then
700 you're not motivated by 70 exactly
right you'd want more than 700 yeah
you'd be like yeah i'll do it but you
know what i know billionaires would
actually be the first people to hit the
water exactly because they understand
money they understand man it's worth me
paying that price to get the 700 because
they know what to do with 700 a lot of
people are not money motivated because
they simply don't know what to do with
money every time they get it they
actually lose it number one you need to
love yourself man
and you need to love your own dreams
so like i always tell i told elena when
we got together i said look man i'll do
anything for you anything literally
anything except one thing
i will not give up my dreams okay if i
am demanded to to to water down my
dreams give up my dreams alter my dreams
to be with you i will not do it okay
because i believe that if i give up on
my dreams which most people do
they'll give up on everybody in their
lives
and and so and that's the way it is
today it's it's my dreams first elena
our marriage and then the kids
you know and and so
um setting that expectation in the
beginning yeah yeah
and
and being like being a strong person
says hey i'm going for what i want
and i think she really trusted that hey
this dude this guy's who he says he is
i'm in your room are broke right now
you're broke you're like just dead broke
like like if i went and banged on your
credit card it would scream and call the
police
now uh alert 9-1-1 call them out right
now this cannot be used again
that's fine dude that's fine you still
need to have your dreams
you need to start dreaming now how old
are you dude
22 years old you got any money at all
but he's got a little he's got a little
diamond in his ear right here he ain't
got any money but he's like look at this
[__]
i'm signing
i'm shining
huh i'm trying to come here come here
man yeah come here man come here
ah
i got a little cubic
[Applause]
come on up here man 22 years old man 22
years old you know what i was doing
every day 22 years old how what do you
weigh man how much you weigh oh you got
one in both ears look at this
get a close-up can you get a close-up
look at that man
oh he's so cool he's so cool look he
looks good too man looks good okay look
how much money do you have to your name
probably like a thousand thousand bucks
what
you're like a million bucks though yeah
yeah
either way bro you're broke
you agree with that oh yeah bro you guys
need to admit it you need to own you
need to know when you're broke the man's
got a thousand dollars
right he goes to jail today
he's broke
so so like but but that does not that
does not mean you can't dream
so right now what he's going to do is he
his dreams are going to be like okay man
like i just want to i just want to get a
a two grand
or i just want to get some of these
or i want to get a watch
that's not the dream folks
you know when you were a kid when you're
a kid 12 years old what do you want you
want a car i can't wait till i get the
car you don't think about i'm gonna own
a car dealership
you think i want a car you don't think
hey man i'm gonna make a new car that
flies
right see that's why he ended up with
these little cubics
[Music]
because his dreams aren't big enough get
off the stage
okay but he's in the right place he's in
the right place everybody agree
i'm 63 years old you know i'll be 64 in
march and
you know i feel like i'm like 14 years
old man i'm like let's roll like let's
let's go i'm ready to run through walls
and
you know fly and learn new stuff i'm
studying uh kryptos right now in the
metaverse and like what happens and when
do i make a play and do i make a play
and what is all this
so you one number one you have to stay
curious
[Music]
number one curious you have to be
curious when clubhouse came around
clubhouse is an audio app if you don't
know what that is
a couple years ago most of the people in
my office including jared's like man
hey nothing there's nothing there
you know i'm like oh there's people
there though
there's people there and what i
discovered because i was curious about
clubhouse is not because i was curious
about social media i was curious about
people
to me i get energy from people
and so uh
i've been in rooms where
uh alan have y'all met alan yet
so alan allen saw me go in a room one
night and he texts me he's like what the
hell you doing in this room man and i
said what's up he's like get out of this
room
and i said what you worried about he's
like you're the only white person in the
room and the title is white entitlement
[Music]
and he sends me a little sweaty emoji
i said bro where how am i going to learn
about white entitlement with white
people
like you got to be curious folks
just because it has nothing to do with
you doesn't mean your market's not there
and for me to be able to market to a
market
means i need to understand how that
market thinks
so one of the great benefits of me being
curious particularly about two-way
communication on on social media the
feedback
i'm not looking for likes and comments
i'm looking for something some
electricity in the moment what you're
talking about the drive potential
potential an idea like all my ideas come
from i don't fabricate ideas
everything you see me do happened it was
happening already in the universe
i don't i don't create anything i just
grab something that's already there
and i grab it out of something i hear
so the supreme court today announced
they kicked out the mandate uh for the
vaccine i'm like hey man [__]
[Applause]
okay good you like it or don't like it
y'all need to get on one side of that
story and start talking to people about
it so you gain that audience
you need to you need oh i don't want to
be political
say that's stupid man
you know there's nothing that raises
more money than politics
nothing there's nothing
and most of it's just a scam and
everybody knows that they're like i'm
throwing in they ain't throwing in for
their side they're throwing in to keep
the other side that they're worried
about
the point of the story is there's energy
there
there's tremendous amounts of energy
that you want to you want to tap into if
you could walk the line and play both of
them that'd be super cool
very difficult to do that though
so when that came out today i'm like
good job man like i got to take a stand
on that now will i lose some people 100
percent
i don't care who i lose there's 8
billion people on this planet
i'm worried about who doesn't know me
so the way to protect your brand
the way to protect your brand is to
expand it
that's the only way to protect your
brand man did you hear that the the
person that won the lottery i got two
points to make here the person that won
the lottery is 84 years old her name is
gloria mc mckenzie
here in florida she'll pay no state
taxes on that winning i keep telling you
guys move to a tax-free state so that
your income's not taxed and hey if you
win the freaking lottery
380 million freaking dollars
you wouldn't be taxed at 10 or 13
percent what are you thinking man the
second point here is this
this woman would not have won this
lottery ticket had it not been for the
guy in front of her being so gracious to
look at 84 and say hey lady you want to
go in front of me i guess he was worried
that she'd die before she could buy the
ticket okay folks in my book called if
you're not first your last
i basically explain
look man if you're first in line you
don't give it up to an 84 year old i
know that might sound you know without
compassion and and uncaring and not
sensitive
hey when you're buying a lottery ticket
get in get out as quick as possible if
you're not first your last in this case
i hope 84 gives this guy a little
squeeze of the cheese please
let's find out how gracious 84 is with
her 380 to the guy that got out of line
to get her in the line
to buy the ticket that won the money
where she don't pay any state taxes in
florida this isn't a magic act these are
basic skills
and basic skills are duplicatable
and the reason most salespeople have
such trouble is because for years we
have been trying sales professionals and
the gurus have been teaching
uh manipulation tactics
dodge the question
don't answer control the customer
uh the the whole newer linguistics bull
these are gimmicks we have never hired
one person that had a neuro-linguistic
background that worked for us
successfully
so you guys are in the lnlp stuff i'm
just telling you we've hired
hundreds and hundreds of salespeople
i've been with tens of thousands of
sales people i have never seen one
person that got into this neuro bull
that was a successful salesperson over
long periods of time and did not bring
drama to our organization
i don't want drama dude i want
production
so
so when when he sits a certain way i
don't start thinking about man um
imagine being in a sales sales
presentation i'm like i got to be like
him and then now i got to be like her
and now i got to be like him guess who
you can't be when you're doing that
you
you man what a diss
i want to be me
the power resonates for me my truth my
authenticity and my transparency
okay so
if you can't do that you can't build you
can't build a business and you certainly
can't duplicate it i never ask him to be
me i'm like hey bro when somebody says
the payments are too high what do you do
what do you say
well i'm with you
everybody try that
no no i didn't say it like that i said
i'm with you
see and i'm with you
hey man hey the price is too high i knew
that before you did
everybody try that
okay see i i'm he he gets to be him
but the words will work because all i'm
doing is basically agreeing with the
customer this isn't a trick here
okay uh this course is uh i'm doing a
dinner tonight for 25 000 at my house
okay i think we got two slots left
the entire 25 000 goes to the grant
cardone foundation any of you want to
put 25 grand in please see one of my
people come have dinner at my house
we'll spend a couple hours over there
the money's going to go to help kids
some of you in a room immediately say
oh my god 25 grand that's a lot of money
man i know that
you don't think i know 25 000 a lot of
money i'm the one that decided what the
freaking entry would be
i said what would be too much 25 grand
25 grand would be a lot of damn money
somebody gonna be like that damn that's
a lot of money okay and the people that
it's a lot of money that think small
that go small and don't want to help
won't come to my house and have dinner
and the people are like dude i'd go
spend two hours with that cat man for 25
grand to get pictures with him at his
new home
with his family
with with eight or ten other people and
the money's going to charity and i get
to write it off i get to bang the irs
who hates the irs
well this is this is the chance to give
them a good
[Music]
okay so you see what i'm doing i'm
handling all the objections right now i
understand 25 grand a lot of money man i
know what you got to do to earn 25 grand
you got to do crazy stuff to earn 25
grand and if you keep thinking that
earning 25 grand is always going to be a
problem for you hopefully for everybody
in a room one day you're going to be
able to earn 25 000 every hour
all commitments require investments in
time and money all commitments
you cannot make a commitment without
time and money being invested
time and money has to be invested you
have to invest time and money
if it's not on your schedule you're not
committed if you don't have money back
by that time on your calendar if it's
not costing you money or you don't have
money deposited right there you are not
committed
where you have your money is where your
personal spiritual emotional physical
commitments go wherever your money is is
who you are most committed to
wells fargo bank of america citibank
you guys many of you got more money at
wells fargo than you have invested in
your own advertising the market
because you guys are committed to the
lie
the big marketing scam of the universe
save your money
what you should do is you should get a
good job first of all you should
avoid borrowing money
unless it's for something that we think
is good for you
right
so first of all you should not bore
money unless
it's one of our credit cards
where we give you points
and one day you too will be able to stay
at a holiday inn for free
where by the way the buffets at the
kitchen are free you can eat all you
want not to mention that you're already
overweight but you could go there
and eat all you want for as long as you
want by the way
if you just borrow enough money on this
card
to buy enough stuff you don't need
to pay us back one day if you can
right and then during the week when
you're not borrowing money from us what
you should do is spend your time getting
money to pay for the
belt that you bought and put on your
credit card
that you can't write off
so this is what americans are doing
people all around the world spend 40
hours a week running around hustling
yeah they get 100 what do they do now
they run over here to the bank drop off
the hundred bucks then they run back out
and do another 40 weeks pick up a
thousand dollars man i had a great week
didn't i bang and then they run over
here and drop it off at the bank these
are the good americans
[Music]
the bad americans go pick up a thousand
bucks go to the club and blow it
the good americans
run run around collecting a thousand
dollars five thousand dollars ten
thousand dollars hustlers hustlers man
hard workers they they get sophisticated
uh i'm gonna put a little money in the
bank over here over here at wells fargo
i'm gonna have a little over here at
citibank i'm gonna spread this
around
i want to be a slave to many
not a slave to a few
i'm going to give a little to the bank
of america i'm going to give a little
bit citibank i'm going to give a little
bit to the wells fargo i'm going to give
a little bit to fidelity and merrill
lynch i'm going to give a little bit to
my ira and my 401k i'm going to bust my
ass i'm going to spend 40 years killing
myself to make sure all these
institutions
have my money
where they pay me
nothing for the sake of security
right and then you guys look up one day
you're like where's my money at it's in
all these accounts by the way what do
those people do with your money when
they get it
they call me
up hey mr cardone
[Music]
we got another dummy
guy spent goddamn he must have spent 160
hours
put together a little bank extremely
disciplined dumbass
and he
saved hundred thousand dollars with us
and we'd like to know mr cardone
if you would like to borrow that money
his
money yeah i sure would because we know
mr cardone that you'll put that money to
work
okay
this guy that gave it to us all he wants
to do is work
i'm like yeah send me that money bro
send me that money okay and they by the
way they're not done calling me they're
gonna call nine other people
they're gonna take his 100 grand and
they're gonna say they're gonna
they're gonna lend it out nine
hundred thousand dollars of it and this
is the banking system
and that is debt by the way
that u.s dollar
okay they're basically multiplying money
if the bank doesn't keep it why do you
spend all your time giving it to them
to keep for you i'm making 2.4 million
dollars a year
if i could figure out how to get another
200 that's called value add v8 value add
if i could figure out how to raise the
rent 200 bucks
units see that's why the number of units
is so apart
106 000
times what
is what one point
[Music]
see that creates another 1 million
274 000 of income a year
i'm already making 2.4 million dollars a
year
bam
that traffic jam
okay i got more cash flow
i just got i don't have to go work i
don't have to beat stuff up
i don't have to go uber you guys are
i'm gonna go uber to what what you go
uber to
you end up with seven dollars
[Music]
same energy folks same energy
spend the energy going someplace getting
a vehicle that can actually get you to
freedom
i don't want money this money i've had
this money here the whole time okay
it ain't gonna do anything
how many got money in the bank right now
it's useless
money is useless until it is put to use
people earn money
and then they spend it
and you're just doing this thing
comes in it goes out
you have to have multiple exits on the
way out
how do i get out of this deal
i know people that have bought real
estate that they're like in cash flows
but they're like i cannot i can never
get rid of this piece of property it's
always going to be a problem for me hang
me around my neck
but it pays me a little bit of money
okay now if it's only one unit if it's
only one unit folks and it makes you 500
a month it's still only 500 a month
everybody agree that's why you don't
want to go small you got to figure out
how to do it big if you do it big if you
do it right if you have the right
location the barriers to entry if you
have the cash flow that you need if you
get good debt on it i promise you you
will not lose money in this space
warren buffett said don't lose money
number two what
number three
exactly so when when i read that i'm
like don't lose money don't lose money
don't lose money
what do i invest in
oh invest in something that doesn't lose
money don't speculate don't buy stocks
like i don't want to trade a piece of
paper for a piece of paper it's a piece
of paper
when you go buy twenty dollars with a
google stock what do you get
you get a piece of paper bag
it's all made up
kids steal it anyway
okay i want something i can see would
you agree
okay i would rather have that that money
i'd rather take this money and say okay
here's a hundred dollars here's a
hundred dollars i'm gonna take the
hundred dollars and i'm gonna buy a flip
chart
this flip chart is more valuable
than that hundred dollars
if i use it
everybody agree okay so i want you to
write this down quit saving money
[Music]
the banks have brainwashed you
save your money save your money save
your money save your money the the wall
street also did this stay liquid stay
liquid stay liquid you want liquidity no
you do not want liquidity you want to be
ill-liquid and you do not want to save
money my wealth ultimately is not the
money i have it's the knowledge i have
and the belief i have in myself the same
thing for you
but i want to take you on this trip
because look number one you got to
visualize it you got to be able to see
it in your mind like possibility second
thing is you got to see it
you know in the physical universe you
can explain to me what a bougainvillea
is you can explain to me what a beach is
you can explain to me what
uh the gym looks like on the second
floor in cabo san lucas at this
beautiful hotel we're at but
until i visually visually physically put
an image to the ocean to the whales
to the sunshine to the mountains until i
visually see it it doesn't become real
third thing you want to do number one
see it in your mind
i was i was doing a call today with
percy miller uh master p
and he's like first thing you got to do
is see it in your mind he grew up in
extreme poverty in the projects and he
says grant first thing i had to do was i
had to see it
in my mind that i could get out second
thing i had to do was see a picture of
it in the physical universe
that's how valuable the internet is
today is that you get to see things that
maybe are way outside your price range
you can see the lambo the rolls the big
house the trip
you can see the possibility of elon
going to mars you know and and all of a
sudden all those things expand
possibilities so number one you've got
to see in the mind too you got to see it
in the physical universe and this also
includes other people examples of other
people that are doing great things i'm
not just talking about physical
manifestation i'm not talking about
stuff
i'm not talking about watches and
bracelets and rings and houses and cars
i'm talking about how can you actually
manifest something in the real world
that you have in your mind how do you
turn an idea
into reality
and uh these things that i'm sharing
with you will make i'll make it a
possibility
uh when you dig deep on them though it's
like okay well how do i get closer to
people that are doing those things
because the third thing is you got to
get closer to the thing you want if you
want a gulf stream
or if you want to solve the water
problem on planet earth you're going to
have to get closer physically closer
step on not just see with your eyes in a
magazine or on the internet you need to
put your feet in the sand put your feet
on the jet
now that might mean that you got to go
fuel jets for a while you got to go work
at an aviation company
an airport and actually fuel them clean
them wash them maybe you got to be a
flight attendant on them put your feet
next to them maybe you have to become a
pilot you're going to have to pay the
price though there's no free lunch here
for anybody including my children
there's no free lunch
there's no way to know what this room
feels like the expansiveness of this
room by looking at it on the internet
the moment you can get in it it'll be
become even more real to you the fourth
thing is you got to put your feet in
this deal
you got to put your feet in this deal
there's a there's a horse down there i
can you can visualize a horse you can
see the horse you you got to touch the
horse in the fourth thing i'm sorry you
got to touch the horse and the fourth
thing is you guys got to collaborate
with other people man you got to get in
the room with other people whether
you're serving water
if they don't invite you to sit down
then offer them money to sit down with
them if that doesn't work
um offer to serve them to sit down okay
there's a story in my life could be
wrapped up in these four things right
here number one see it in my mind number
two see it in the physical universe like
see it in in some not physical but in
metaverse
on the internet in a magazine a picture
of it third get closer to it put your
feet on it on the plane on the horse on
the beach in the hotel if i got to go
work there to do it and the fourth thing
is
you got to network with people that have
stuff
okay
again uh i spent some time this week
with uh dame dash she's like look you
got to get close to the action you got
to get with the people that are making
the moves you cannot make the moves from
your own neighborhood uh percy miller
told me you cannot make the moves from
the projects you got to move from the
projects not make the moves in the
project quit working street corners
quit selling just a product and start
hanging out with people that have scaled
their think their ideas
into a reality you have to prepare for
inflation hitting you
and
look i just want to give you a heads up
on this thing it's happening right now i
believe we're already in a recession not
to be a doomsday guy because i think
that there's ways for you to take
advantage of this but i just passed one
two three four five six shops and
nobody's in them
so the american consumer has like 18
trillion dollars between cash accounts
and money markets you can't get negative
right now when you see the bad news this
is an opportunity for you and your
family to actually expand
not contract
so you're going to see bad news in the
headlines everywhere once the the
politicians start allowing
the mass media to actually distribute
the bad news and we're not talking about
you crane and covid we're not talking
about abortion uh
rulings because all that is just
distraction for the bigger problem which
is the economy
the economy is problematic okay you got
the fed pushing interest rates
uh half a point yesterday
there was a rebound in the stock market
this morning i wake up the stock market
rolls over by a thousand points okay
there's going to be blood in the market
so i'm going to do a training on this
i'm going to give you a few tips right
now but i'm going to click i'm going to
give you a link to a training for those
of you who actually want to do something
about this and not just hear the bad
news
and be woken up first thing is you got
to wake up you got to wake up to what's
happening you got to know that hey
what do i do now what do i do if this
happens one do not buy into the bad news
okay two you got to expand into the
opportunity and it's very very difficult
to do
uh you've heard of wealthy people doing
this before how they take advantage of
situations okay i'm gonna show you how
to do that whether you have cash or no
you don't have cash whether you have
credit or don't have credit
because during times of contraction what
happens is
for instance there's 32 million small
businesses in america
many of you are going out trying to
start a new business where what you
ought to do is just kind of slide
sideways and go buy one the neighbor
next door to you
i mean from laundry mats to plumbers to
internet businesses to coaching
businesses you name it chiropractors
dentists like in every sector that
you're involved in right now in your
business or your interests or your
passion i'll promise you
there are
thousands
thousands not one or two but thousands
of small businesses like yours
that are similar to your passion that
would feed your passion that already
have branding already have marketing
built in already have a name already
have a location already have revenue
already have credit lines that you could
literally just slide into
okay but you're not going to do that
you're not going to do that if all
you're doing is buying into bad news
so number one you can't buy into the bad
news because
remember all bad news sooner or later
is beat out by the need to survive in
the economy to go on the economy will
always go on
okay not just here in america but around
the world always always always we always
get on the other side of bad news so the
first thing you do is you got to keep
your head out of the garbage dump
you got to stay positive and trust me
when it goes negative
it is not easy to stay positive
people always like oh yeah i can stay
positive on my own probably not because
you're not gonna be on your own you're
gonna be surrounded by bad news
everywhere so number two you got to
think about how do you expand despite
the fact that you don't have money and
you don't have credit or you do have
money and you do have credit but you
don't want to use either one because
you're terrified
and you will be
the third thing you have to figure out
to do okay is exactly what sectors will
survive
long term
what sectors are going to win through
contractions because what happens in a
contraction
what happens is weak businesses get
squeezed out weak names get squeezed out
okay a weak operators get squeezed out
and the strong come in and take over
that either the technology takes over
and disrupts the space or a person
typically a person or an operator comes
in and then scales that business
now what i'm going to look to do here in
the next couple years is actually
accelerate my expansion
accelerate my expansion because i know
how to operate i know the four things
you have to do in a business to make a
business successful there's only four
things you must do to keep a business
one profitable two expanding and three
flourishing
there's four things and only four things
okay i don't have time right now because
i'm with my family uh but but when you
click the link below what i'll do is
i'll give you a free training on those
four things that you have to do look you
will get through this i promise you're
gonna get through this the question is
you're gonna get through it and you're
gonna do great you're gonna flourish and
prosper you're gonna be like these
businesses waiting waiting
for traffic so how do you get through
stuff you gotta have targets the the
thing that probably gets me through
everything is this where am i going
you know what is the target
i can do anything for a short period of
time if it gets me to a target
significant enough to change and improve
the quality of my life
i can do almost anything
as long as the target's big enough and
changes my life and the lives of other
people
if you ask me to uh change a flat and my
bro i ain't changing a flat
i don't know how to change a flat i'll
tear the car apart just finding the
little thing in the back so i tried the
last time i worked on a car i was 16
years old i tried to change a starter in
a 1970 ford maverick
took me four days
and it should take like 12 minutes
uh because i don't know what i'm doing
so you know you need a target that is
you know big enough
to change to change the quality of your
life
i need a target big enough
to change the quality of my life
otherwise everything that pops up in my
life
will become a distraction to my life
so covid hit
bang man i just got more excited
i'm like okay nobody's stopping me from
this target
when the government tells me i have to
force a vaccine on the people that work
for me i get more resilient on my
position and that's got nothing to do
with the vaccine it's got something to
do with people forcing me like you you
cannot suppression never works folks
for people that are alive and committed
to a target suppression is fuel
the attempt to suppress or stop
creates the the greatness of who you are
diamonds are made under pressure so
these moments that are tough like
i is it really a big event is it one and
a half years of your kid's life where's
the target because you're looking in the
past right now if i'm on the pass it's
cause i lost my target i used to listen
to guys that were millionaires
and they were like when i look back now
i'm like oh they were all like don't get
bigger bigger is not better fly under
the radar
uh you know it what matters is how much
you make how much you net how much you
keep save your money everything all
those guys that are worth two and three
and four million even some guys are
worth five and ten they're all about
contraction that's right they're trying
to say conservative because when you
start talking to these other dudes i'm
not talking about myself now when i get
around guys there were 600 million
800 4 billion
they never talk about that dude they
think my money's chunk money they're
like
that's not money right there dude look
look quit looking at your notes okay
what do you want to do here what's in my
notes
nobody said you okay what do you want
what does tommy need to do
tommy's making 400 grand worried about
somebody that's no good
okay
where does tommy need to go
screw the mechanics
okay where you've been screw where
you've been
do where where are you in the right
vehicle you have to change
okay where you been
means nothing
not none of this the the chick that you
hired in new orleans
what you did last year dude none of it
matters where are you going to go no no
you just want to skip now dude you just
want to drop the past
it doesn't matter okay so my goal for
you i don't know if it's your goal but
i'm hearing you say some of this
let's just go to number one in your
market it's easy to do to have life
balance you got to have money like yeah
this is the taboo thing to say it's
never going to be on tv nobody likes you
got to have money nobody's nobody ever
says this yeah oh yeah i do this i do
that i have uh
dude you got to have money you can't you
can't
you know what do i mean by that like
okay well like create the life you want
yeah quit saving money
you know quit buying watches and h-belts
like i don't have an herb maze built
like i didn't know how to pronounce our
maze i'm like who would spend seven
eight hundred bucks on a belt like like
i could buy three thousand dollars worth
of real estate with a 700 belt right and
who am i trying to impress anyway what i
need is i need a trainer to come to me
so you buy your army's belt i'ma buy a
trainer to come to me i don't want to go
to him
okay i know
time is money
it's not money it's time it's time is
money so
why am i going to get a car in drive
to to to to the trainer
here you go i'll give you another 200
bucks you come to me
okay you come to me i walk down there i
do my workout boom i'm done well he's
he's still driving 40 minutes
he's and i'm already taking a shower and
doing a business deal
so you got to figure out the things in
your life
you know when i when i when i went from
okay i'm never going to do i'm never
going to work for below my pay grade
anymore
like this was a big shift for me
like i like gardening i like landscape
stuff right when i got rid of a yard i
was like that was that that probably
made me 10 million bucks
i loved it i spent too much time doing
it it was costing me money was below my
pay grade
you know you see what i'm saying like
what am i doing what am i doing like oh
because it's therapeutic well good man
like like not two hours of it
therapeutics costing you millions of
dollars because you're out there playing
with stuff that made me feel good and
everything but there's got to be a
faster better way to do that to get that
sensation i say this all the time like
if you love
if you learn to love the thing you hate
you might find a big gift in it and for
me i didn't like sales i hated it i
tried selling when i was 17 years old
lost a job 18 i tried again part time
during the summer lost the job
19 years old lost the job i had had five
experiences in sales and hated every one
of them all different industries i just
kept moving industries thinking okay
it'll be different
this will be easy to sell i hated sales
i hated talking to people i particularly
hated the beginning the rapport building
you know i'm not good at breaking ice
like ron secco he can talk to anybody i
can't do that i can't go into a room um
i could speak to 35 000 people but i
can't go into a room and start warming
it up
it's just i'm uncomfortable so
the point i'm trying to make is when i
was 25 the only job i could get was a
sales job and i said hey you got to
decide that you're going to get good at
this even if you hate it yeah because
you can't lose another job it would have
been my sixth firing and i'm like i
cannot lose another job i did by the way
get fired from that place but they never
got rid of me because i kept selling
yeah so every time they'd fire me i'd be
i'd go back and sell something they'd be
like okay
stay another day until the next time you
mess up something so
you know i went from hating sales
to committing to it to becoming now
known as like one of the greatest living
sales people on the planet
so
in the things you hate yeah like where
does the hate come from like the things
that you hate
the things that just grind you out like
you're gonna just bug you there's
probably if you just stay with it and
look just move to the side a little bit
and look behind it there might be some
great absolutely the problem was i was
not i do what a lot of entrepreneurs do
the mistake a lot of entrepreneurs make
is number one they never look up the
definition entrepreneur
an entrepreneur means someone is who
organizes a business or businesses and
invests money takes greater than normal
risk with money in order to expand or
organize those businesses
i wasn't spending money on my business
like all i was doing was knocking on
doors it was just pure effort i wasn't
spending money like
i wouldn't spend real money until i was
uh 50 50 years old about 10 years ago
when a guy said bro you're not a
business
and i said what he and i could feel this
yeah i was a hustler i was a grinder
but i wasn't a business and i and i
could feel it you know
um yeah i was a consultant i could i was
making some money like in my 30s and 40s
i made you know i made a lot of money
what other people would call a lot of
money yeah but i was not a business you
know what i mean i was just what do you
mean by that well i was just hustling
just because you're hustling
everything was a transaction yeah
everything everything was a transaction
to get money pay the taxes have a little
bit of money left over everything was a
transaction yeah and um
and this guy's like well you know you're
not a business
and i was like i know man i know don't
tell anybody i know that okay like i
knew it
and because because to me a business is
i can walk away from it'll still operate
i was i was a guy i was no different
than when i was 30 just pounding doors
and which was good which was good and i
think a lot of people need to you don't
need to skip that spot either
because once i put the two together okay
i can pound the door i can learn
e-commerce
um i can be i can be a one-product sale
i could sell to companies like today
we'll sell we'll sell a product to a
company for
80 grand on a on a three to five year
contract 80 grand a year
and i'll switch immediately and sell an
8 product online or i'll give something
away for free
to speaking to 4 000 people today in
hopes that i can meet
you know maybe 40 of them that i can do
have a partnership and a collaboration
with
in the future what you become is what
you will be
most people are sitting in a student
chair too long you're learning you like
learning studying reading you know
trying to get information dude the way
that the way to trick the system is to
become something as fast as possible
don't keep learning
buy something this is the easiest
simplest way for somebody to become an
investor
i did the deal i bought the deal with my
money did the research with my money my
time my energy in my 30 years
i use my cred
with the banks and the real estate
community to get the deal
that deals 260 million dollars
your entire audience could not buy that
deal by itself even if it had the money
because it doesn't have the connection
yep
so i'm paying i'm buying the deal with
my money
and my bank my my debt
then once i buy it and close it i've
taken all this risk out
because once i buy it and close it then
i offer it up to my audience to say same
price that i pay you can get in at
one thousand dollars five thousand ten
thousand whatever number you're
comfortable with
so what happens is one your money is
protected against inflation and
deflation okay against the destruction
and destruction of the dollar which is
what what's happening right now is they
are purposely destroying the dollar the
very thing they told you for the last 30
years you should save
and you should you should
you know trade your most valuable asset
for they are now destroying the very
thing that you've been saving
and they're penalizing you for having it
because they pay you nothing to keep it
understand that a thousand and i'm gonna
answer your whole question here
understand that a thousand dollars today
at bank of america or wells fargo
let me see a thousand dollars today
times pays one dollar and 20 cents
[__] let me see yeah that's one
dollar and twenty cent anyway
crazy okay now that's before you bought
your checks that's before you started
the the checking account that's before
you use the atm by the time the end of
the years your thousand dollars probably
more like 920 bucks probably cost you 80
bucks just to have a checking account
so number one you become an investor
number two you get cash flow every
quarter number three i expect that
building to be a double or a triple so
i'm paying 260 for the building if i
sell it for 340 we make a double
i think the building is going to sell
for 500 million when i sell it
location's ridiculous can't replace it
it's 99 occupied right now it's a trophy
quality asset it's in fort lauderdale
florida one of the hottest markets in
the country and when i sell this
i will be selling it to an institution
and the reason that's important is
because most of us that are earning 50
bucks a night
you have to buy the leftovers man
you know the the we're buying leftovers
we're buying we're buying the garbage in
the community the duplex
the single family home
these are the same homes they went back
to the banks in 2010 and you don't want
to be in that stuff what you want to be
is the trophy stuff
that somebody always finds value in yeah
so i think the return is uh five to six
percent in the first year
paid out quarterly
uh we passed through the depreciation to
you so you won't be paying taxes for the
first couple of years on your income
um and i think you get a double or
triple
off your money so if you put in 10 grand
i think you're looking at your money
being 20 or 30 000 over the next uh five
six seven years this is insanity that p
that you're being told don't monetize
your your business if you have a good
business have a good service have a good
product sell it
you know but so many guys are they're
they're trying these little kid kid
gimmicks
you know it's fine if my kids flip shoes
on on on ebay
if you're an adult man you got to get
beyond flipping
sneakers on ebay
you need to build a business
otherwise don't call yourself an
entrepreneur because that's not what an
entrepreneur an entrepreneur is not
flipping [__] on ebay
that's not a business
that's you trying to make two dollars on
a toy that you bought at a garage sale
it's a different gig
now if you can figure out how to scale
that
but it sounds to me like you're you're
benefiting ebay more than you're
benefiting yourself
ebay is the pimp and you're basically
the prostitute in that machinery which
is no problem with that right
but you're servicing the machine rather
than building your own machine
i want to build a machine
i want to build a machine that lives
longer than i do so that if i get a good
partnership with somebody and we cut a
deal and they're 90 of the profits in
future and i'm 10 and my kids and my
charity get to keep that 10 after i'm
dead man i'm good to go
so what's next like got the jet like
what what's next man
man i don't know what's 10 x for you now
10x is you know how do i do a billion
dollars a year in in income
and then how do i do 10 billion in real
estate how do i have a 10 billion dollar
real estate portfolio we pay last month
we paid
uh 1.4 million dollars out in
distribution i'm sorry last month we
paid 1.4 million in u.s dollars out to
our term investors in the real estate
how do i start competing with these
banks so they're like you know what we
really don't like all this noise you're
making you're a noisy [__] guy and
we're kind of getting tired of it now
when you get noisy enough they either
buy you and suppress you
you know that's what bill gateswood did
with with apple years ago the tablet the
original iphone was a little uh called
uh
what was the name of that little beast
um
anyway it had a little pin you wrote on
they buried that project for years
um i'll think of it in a second i think
of it when the interview's over maybe
you guys know what it is okay anyways
probably 20 years ago i actually had a
company built around this thing and bill
gates came in gave apple steve jobs
alone and said look i'll lend you this
money
you got to bury that product
and they did
so that's what you can do or they
consume you they buy you and say hey we
want you to be part of our
so maybe maybe that's what happens
nathan i don't know
i don't know get to get the audio guy
the audio guy to get a good sticker for
the mic spirituality is the number one
one most important thing to me in my
life like
before my wife and my kids is my
understanding of god yeah and and my
dreams come from that connection and
that understanding and my my dreams and
my goals are not really financial it's
potential
so so when i talk about
you know people ask me
the probably the most painful question i
get is when is enough enough
and i'm like man you guys are to check
in with god on that
yeah right because because my my
potential
is what i'm going after it's not it's
not some number i got a guy asking me
about my net worth i'm like dude what it
was it's a stupid question
it's an ego it's an ego it's an ego
thing right what i'm interested is my
potential possibility discovery
and and and for me that potential is the
thing that strings me and god
and that potential is my dreams it's
like what what could i do what's
possible
and the the other thing is about the
blessing you know you hear people i was
in atlanta i'm like man i'm blessed and
everybody's like oh yeah praise the lord
i'm like yeah everybody's blessed
everybody's blessed i've never met
somebody that's not blessed
most people are not proving it though
they're blessed and not validating god
every day
so uh i have a very very powerful very
strong and very clear
understanding of my relationship with
god and it is first and foremost with me
other people won't understand it right
but but but i every every day every day
every deal undoing a deal
like i've undone deals hey guys this
deal is no longer good for me
and that was me at my my highest ethical
what do you mean you got a deal we got a
deal you signed a contract that's right
and now we're going to undo this deal
and i'm going to undo it we're going to
talk about it we're going to figure it
out
hey hey this deal is not good for me and
if it's not good for me it's not good
for my family it's not good for my
future it's not good for my my ability
to give to charities
it's not good for you either
so rather than me just walking away why
don't we just rework the deal so that
we're both happy and everybody wins very
difficult thing to do
are you allowed because another person
driver because another person might be
bound by that agreement they're like no
no we have a deal i have to do what i
said i'm going to do because they're
bound by some rule that they made some
agreement hey if that agreement's no
longer good for you no god
would want you to continue what you'd
want to do is communicate which is
harder to do yeah you know so so
the ability for my wife and i to
communicate about anything even if it's
tough and it's you know it's
you know how having believing in god is
more than just believing in god it takes
courage
to to go out every day and validate it
because if you actually believe you have
to do and you ought to do well too and
if you ever you know to me in my mind
like
you know if i have if i have a good
really strong good working relationship
with god i would be successful at
everything physically
in my marriage in business with my
customers online
i would have good reviews not bad
reviews
yeah like
you ought to have the whole package i
don't think
i know i don't think god had a part
partial package i think it was probably
the whole deal
and the other thing is the work thing
you know like
i see a lot of people that believe in
god that don't work
you know they're like oh yeah but you
know
they're taking two and three days off
god don't even take that much time off
he takes one day off yeah look what he
did before he took the day off one of
the things that
to me is the most difficult thing in my
entire career is becoming a top producer
because the moment you become a top
producer
you become susceptible
to thinking you have the life
i grew up in a little town in louisiana
a little small town about 60 000 people
uh you probably hear the accent
and uh i grew up in a middle class a
middle class family my my dad died when
i was 10 years old my mother raised us
and my mother constantly told me how
proud i should be of myself
how many of you got a mother like that
you should be so proud of yourself okay
every time my mom was my best friend and
every time i would have a success it
didn't matter whether i was 18 years old
or 48 years old anytime i had a success
she was the first person i called i
wouldn't call my girlfriend wouldn't
call my wife wouldn't call any of the
the people that were closest to me i
called my mom and said mom you never
believe i just bought a real estate deal
i started this company i bought my first
real estate deal was 38 units it's 4
million and she'd be like that's awesome
i love you just the way you are
and i'm like okay okay thanks she told
me that a thousand times how many had a
parent tell you i love you that's great
that's great you made 160 grand last
year
but i love you just the way you are
let me hear that
okay that's right out of the 10x rule i
don't know if you know that that's right
out of the four actions
anybody know what action is
average average i'm doing well
okay there's four levels of action
number one is i do nothing
if i rewrote this book i would take that
out that's actually impossible to do
nothing at all it's impossible try doing
it right now
to do nothing means you had to make a
decision to do something and not do it
this is actually not true i wouldn't put
it in the book if i rewrote it the
second level of action is
to retreat this is what most people do
by the way
how many had a commitment to work out
today
and didn't
okay again
i was up late whatever you came up with
whatever reason i'm gonna make the call
by the way any retreat in life any
single retreat
is a discipline and a commitment
to retreat when it matters
so so every time you make a decision you
just need to be aware
that what are you doing here okay
there's only four things you can do in
any given day right you could do nothing
you could retreat or you could do this
average
now i know you guys are being told that
you're the top
you're the best you made it to miami but
i'm just going to tell you right now
ain't
not a person in this room
is above number three
no i'm not there
okay and i know how much i'm grinding
every day how much i'm pushing every day
how how many how many hours i put into a
day what's the maximum number of hours
you can do in a day
not if you add people
if you added people you got to think
beyond the 24th thing once you guys get
committed once you get committed then
you will come up with solutions outside
the physical universe
okay you're already doing that your
space is your space is bizarre okay
here there's a bunch of people in the
room that
that like i don't know anything about
technology
i'm 61 years old i was born in 1958 i am
supposed to be outside of that moment of
technology yet i'm probably one of the
top five social media people in the
world today
banging on instagram and snapchat and
linkedin and
google plus that'll go away using all
these mechanisms to try to get attention
so that i can operate
at this level 10x thing this massive
level that is always changing by the way
you can't 10x something people are like
man i'd write the book if i wrote the
book i'd write it 11x
i'm like that's because you don't
understand 10x dude 10x is a multiplier
it's 10x which is 100.
okay so what what i do what i did in it
when lehman collapsed
i wrote the 10x rule and i wrote the
book because i realized i had done
something wrong that book was written
for me
and the reason when i closed the book
the reason i was like whatever i had
figured out what i had done wrong okay i
had to
embrace the the the idea that three or
four million dollars in a bank and a
house paid for and two cars and a
marriage and i got it better than
everybody else and my mama loves me just
the way i am
was all this this middle class
this american particularly here in
america how many of you live in america
okay in america the middle class
it is the sleeping chamber
on planet earth
okay people come here people come here
they come from india and china come to
here to get a middle class dude i don't
want anything to do with this
okay your middle class you will not
change the world you might change your
house you might change the education
your little kids get
okay they get to go to texas a m big
deal
right
he told me that he went to texas i said
oh that had to screw you up bad just
going to college wow because what are
they manufacturing college
they they manufacture average people at
college
so so i want to challenge you today okay
i want to challenge you today i want to
challenge you today to start thinking
hey wait a minute am i even a top
producer three things you got to know
about money and the same three rules
hold true for attention number one you
got to get it
you don't need to make it
it's already been made there's trillions
and trillions of dollars
there's more money on this planet than
there are iphones
okay endless supply
okay it's like it's garbage by the way
you need to understand it's garbage
once i get it the thing to do is once i
get it now i don't want to lose it how
do i not lose it i take it and i convert
it to something more valuable than money
so as fast as i can i'm gonna take this
cash
that i earned i don't spend it ever
never spend this money no matter how big
the bag is i take the entire urn bag
and i dump it into something that
becomes that will produce passive income
for it the only thing i ever spend is
the hundred dollars that comes out of
the building not the bag that i earn
because of my talent
i take my talents
i get paid for them i shift it into the
building the money goes away
money can't be lost now it's been
converted to concrete glass steel
tenants leases
uh real property okay it goes up in
value over time this
gets destroyed over time
it can be getting burnt it can get torn
it can get lost it can get uh stolen
so i want to get rid of this illiquid i
want to get ill liquid in the building
convert it to something real and then i
want to wait when i get paid passive
income
this passive income is not taxed
it's only taxed it's taxed up a small
tiny percentage of what earned income is
so i keep most of it and this is how i
live i live off of this money
and and i could spend all of this
or i could take this and start investing
in more buildings
the way you talk about it get it
get it keep it number two you got to
keep it how do i keep it i don't save it
at the bank
when you put it the bank the bank is
going to tax it
cash is taxed
all cash is taxed okay cash is not king
cash flow is king so what you want is
you want this you want passive income
and the third thing you want to do is
you want to figure out how to multiply
that building will multiply over time
there's nobody that's going to tell me
that building will not be more money
right location
like like the cities we're buying in
austin
houston dallas orlando tampa
the carolinas nashville tennessee
atlanta georgia freaking on fire
savannah georgia anything in the in the
smiley part of the united states where
new york when the back seat when they
came out last night and said hey we're
mandating i got calls from three buddies
i'm [__] done with new york
i thought they were gonna change they're
not new york is gonna feed that building
20 of our tenants right now
are from new york city 10 are from
california moving from la all the way
over to miami
so people are tired of the [__] man
and and and and when they're tired of
that what they do is they move and when
they move they rent first they don't buy
first i want my employees to stay broke
[Music]
i don't want employees sitting with cash
cash means porsches
and porsches mean he's going to be in
trouble every person i've ever seen work
for me that does this stuff before they
get their investments right they go buy
junk
h belts big watches they can't afford
the new one they're a real ubloa so they
go buy a big you know 80 watch dude when
you start seeing indicators of that
people start playing all that stuff
they're doing bottle service over at
live on the weekends acting like
free money
will end up at lyft
so steve steve when you came to work for
me how much money were you making
three thousand dollars a month three
grand a month okay you can't live on
three grand a month in miami every day
we would tell them you cannot live on
three grand a month in miami it's
impossible just tell them so it's
impossible
so re tell people the truth is it the
truth
can you live on three thousand dollars
in any city in america
not without fear
you can live on it but not without fear
and that's what you need to tell your
people folks you need to leave here if
you want your people all on the same
page how many like to have everybody
highly motivated say yay
how many like to have everybody around
you
really engaged
how many of you like to be surrounded by
friends
that are actually talking about
hey let's all do better
rather than make sense of how they're
doing
okay how many of you'd like to
pay for the fuel in my plane for us to
go someplace
but you can't
and that's a damn shame
okay like that that's that should be
your goal hey i want grant to pick me up
are you gonna pick me up in your plane
like think that big folks
think that big get people around you
thinking that big all right when you go
to dinner don't worry about hey guys
okay uh
let's all throw the card in
really
you should be fighting to pay for the
bill
the money's out there it's not your
money
it's this every business i have five
companies now we'll do a hundred million
this year i started every one of those
companies with no money zero money man
just hustle and grit and courage
i've called on people i didn't want to
be with i've done things i didn't want
to do okay it is not about doing what
you love it's about doing whatever it
takes
to make your dreams a reality to be
closed and stay closed if you're not
closed on your product if you're not
buying your own product why would you
expect anybody else to
man 400 bucks is a lot of money your
prospect says to you 400
do it
listen to me man you're 32 years old
you've been trying to save money for 20
years and you hadn't do it and do it now
i don't need anything special here i'm
not going to be empathetic
quit being stupid write to check
i don't know if the compliance guy likes
that or not
but i know this look if you believe in
what you're selling how many of you
believe in what you're selling
then close the deal
then close the deal okay learn to close
and you'll never be without work you'll
never be without money you'll have an
organization that is booming in
affluence
you'll have a pipeline full you'll have
appointments filled up
right i call it a a group called me
yesterday i'm actually trying to do a
deal with cnbc and the guy says i'm
interested i said good i'll be there
tomorrow call me back i'll be i'm flying
into new york tomorrow what am i trying
to do right now by the way i was
supposed to be here
[Music]
i'll fly into new york tomorrow i can be
there tomorrow mr ackerman okay how does
that work
i can't do tomorrow i was going to be
here anyway i'm trying to close the bid
let me close the deal i'll figure out
how to be in two places at one time
later
right you some of you in the room
they're like hey i can see you at four
o'clock on tuesday right and the
customer says to you i'll see you at 4
o'clock
let me look at my calendar like like
you're so busy
dude that is so old
that is so old and it's dishonest
[Music]
it's dishonest man
you want to see me tuesday four o'clock
i give you tuesday at four o'clock agree
to it
done
done i'll call you if something changes
if there's an earthquake between now and
next tuesday tuesday morning there's a
massive earthquake and i can't be there
you think everybody'll understand
commit first figure to rest out later
close the deal right now fill your
calendar up your calendar's got the
devil all over it
white space on a calendar and you will
meet the devil
you don't need to die okay you go two or
three days without anything going on how
many of you start having doubts
you're in hell
oh my god this ain't gonna work for me
there's nobody coming in i'm not gonna
hit my target okay i know what i'll do
i'll lower my target
that's the devil doing that man that's a
criminal
never ever if you're taking notes never
lower a target
never lower a target never lower a
target your mom and dad would tell you
to lower a target a manager might tell
you to lower target be reasonable
[Music]
be reasonable with yourself
just bring it down a little bit no man
criminal products are created like that
a guy sees the girl that he wants that's
the girl
she says no he goes to another girl
right he gave up on his dream
if you're going to give up in your own
dream how are you going to build an
organization i'm going to tell you this
for everybody in the room you will never
ever experience great change in your
life
unless you're willing to give up
something that you have right now
every single time in my life
i have had to give up something i wanted
i'm not talking about getting rid of the
bad stuff you got to get rid of
something that you actually worked for
to get
it might have been the house
it might have been oh my kids are in the
best schools now it's going to be
something painful for you to get to the
next place you have to give up something
that you worked for really really hard
so i sold my house one day i had this
cognition hey to get what you want you
have to give up what you have
that has been true for me throughout my
entire life i had to leave lake charles
louisiana went went to houston had to
leave houston once i got comfortable
with my community and my friends had to
leave san diego had to go to l.a l.a is
a pit
compared to la jolla nobody goes from la
jolla california up to los angeles
nobody does that you'll leave kansas
city to go to los angeles
because you want to be an actor i met
elena within five minutes of arriving in
l.a i sold my house i sold my house i
didn't leave it vacant
as a backup plan i left this house okay
like i couldn't buy this house today if
i wanted to it was so like it was a
precious little treasure
i had to give that up by the way i had
to give up being the mayor of my little
town everybody knew me it wasn't a
restaurant i couldn't walk into i could
always get a seat i could always get the
best seat i had it right in my hand this
is what i'm telling you guys you have to
be willing to give something up and the
moment you do you better have your
partner on your side
whoever's in your life mom whoever's the
big influence that significant other
person in your life
that you're going to consult that
everybody's going to consult every one
of you are going to hey what do you
think should i
you better have that person on your side
in my case i was by myself
so my consultant was like you going to
do this dog i called my buddy dale dale
you think i should he's like you're
miserable bro you got everything you
want and you're miserable
he's like what do you have to risk
sold the house
went to los angeles lived in a hotel i
went from a a house on the ocean to
living in a hotel the hotel room was
probably like i don't know maybe the
size of this stage so please please do
whatever you got to do this weekend to
figure out whatever you got to do to get
rid of whatever is holding you back most
of which is something you worked hard to
get
okay maybe before the weekend's over you
could write down two or three or four
things you worked really hard to get
that you think you're supposed to keep
you got them already you got it you
already did that you don't have to keep
it people say the dumbest things it
could be family it could be your wife
your husband it could be a a mom a dad a
uncle an aunt it could be your kids
coming from school people say what they
think and what they think will be what
they say and what they say and think
often enough long enough reinforced
enough i promise you will be what they
do okay so look at some of the dumb
things you say like this here's one dumb
thing people say
time heals all things
really
you get a splinter in your foot and you
don't pull the splinter out you don't
look at it confront it and say i gotta
pull that little
booger out i gotta pull that little
splinter out if you just leave it there
you might get used to it yeah you'll get
used to it 30 years goes by you still
got a splinter in your foot who knows
that splinter gets into your bloodstream
goes to your heart spikes your heart
kills you time does not heal all things
folks you know it heals all things
taking a look at it having the courage
to look at it hey what happened to me
how did i screw up here what what hurt
or what pain or what happened that i had
a loss i see people go through life with
all these losses unwilling to look at
them all crippled by the time they get
older not old but they looking old
because they believe that time heals
look time heals when you confront it
when you look at it when you pull the
splinter out and take responsibility for
it don't believe everything you believe
you know what i'm saying because some of
the ideas you got they just dumb
and dumb things will cause you to do
dumb things get excited you better get
excited now because if you're not going
to get excited now nobody will give you
this money
nobody will give you this money money
follows attention how much attention can
i get in the marketplace is where money
goes money does not go to the best
product ever
money does not go to the best product
money does not go to the happiest place
either money goes to where attention
goes whoever gets the most attention
gets the most money action massive
action has always worked it's proven
itself for thousands of years this is
not a new concept
you show me somebody and we know their
name anybody anybody in the in the room
any famous person
that you can think of
anybody that we would both know you say
i'm going to mention their name and
grant will know who that is
give me a name of one person
massive action
persistent massive action
okay
okay how many people were watching the
open yesterday
yeah exactly why
because tiger was in it
attention money follows attention
money follows attention how much
attention can you get even bad attention
okay i'm gonna tell you something
what tiger went through in the last
decade helped him
you got more white people pulling for
tiger woods
right they're like tiger grown white men
tiger and we say there's division in
this country tiger i love tiger
right why because they love a comeback
man the guy got a lot of attention
okay who else give me another name
oh my god i didn't i didn't know it was
going to be this kind of meeting
if i didn't know there's going to be
this kind of me i'd charge a double
donald trump donald trump
everybody knows it okay money follows
attention success and power follow
attention okay you cannot like the guy
but could you handle
that much heat
every day
could you handle that many people not
liking you every day
because if you're going to be a leader
if you're going to be a real leader okay
if you're going to be at the top of the
food chain kind of leader people aren't
going to like you money is garbage
it's garbage it's not it's not really
what you want because it gets taxed
heavily
so and this is another thing the
ballplayers don't understand this most
the middle class doesn't understand it
the guy making 50 racks a year the guy
making 500 racks a year doesn't
understand it guy working at facebook
doesn't understand he knows how to code
he don't know how to beat the tax man
and the way to beat the tax ban is with
real estate it is the last
venue
where and i'm not talking about a house
i'm talking about buying like this piece
of real estate right behind me right
there that piece of real estate is 260
million dollars
now i didn't start with that my first
deal was
my first deal was a three million deal i
made 5 million on it one deal
and paid no taxes
and when i did that first deal man i did
i put 350 grand down i borrowed it from
my mom and a brother
uh and made five i turned 350 grand into
five million dollars and didn't have to
go through the [__] that i was going
through every single day
and i'm like oh my god this is a game
man when i went to file my taxes the guy
showed me how not to pay taxes on it i'm
like okay i'm good
and i've been doing that i now have four
billion dollars worth of real estate i
started with 300 grand borrowed money i
got four billion dollars this deal right
here is a quarter of a billion
and what i've learned over the last 25
years is this game is on its own it's a
rigged game and it's on stack
it's all it's all stacked against the
little guy in the middle guy
and so what i decided to do was was uh i
promised my mom when i was 15 years old
dorian i said if i ever make it i'm
gonna help the little guy out
because i grew up with a single mother
five kids she was freaking frightened
all that she never got a shot at that
stuff
you know if my family got to buy a house
that they had we had you got to pay for
if we could buy a house and pay it off
that was freaking like that was the
american dream
that ain't a dream bro that's prison
that right there behind me
cash flow day one
trophy asset
appreciation two and three and four
times most of this real estate's been
doubling every every decade
uh trophy institutional quality great
write-offs everything the wealthy look
for in an investment so i'm buying this
deal and then i open it up to my friends
and followers on facebook instagram tick
tock thousand dollars
with a thousand dollars you can partner
with me in that deal
and it's important for everybody to know
like oh my god this guy's going to raise
money from everybody
i could have gotten one company one bank
would have given me the entire
amount of money that i'm raising for my
friends
one one bank said hey i'll give you the
whole two i'll give you all the money
for the deal and you you'd be the
partner in the deal grant you run the
deal will be the money
and i didn't take the money because i
want my friends my followers the people
on this i want to give people a shot
so uh because you're easier to deal with
dorian i'd rather you be my partner in
the deal than bank of america for me
like i was always scared of money you
know and and i was terrified of it so so
like if you look at still today like i
look at the bill of everything
it's a bill of everything
if something caused something i want to
know how much it was
and so like
how much is it like i'm going to ask
that question
whether whether it matters or not um it
doesn't matter where i get in my life i
don't think i'm ever going to be free of
how much was that how much is the dinner
how much how much was dinner how much
was the tip how much was the code how
much was the jacket what did you know me
me and elena like elena's like hey it's
going to be fine man like look what look
look look look at what you've done we
cannot spend this and i'm like how much
was it
i want to know how much it was because
when i grew up do you had to know what
things cost
and so the point your question about
money is it's a terrifying thing because
it's the one thing in life
that
you know the nfl is not going to give me
the ball
and and i'm never going to get a chance
to golf i can't win in those
environments but with money
everybody gets money it's the one place
where everybody gets it and now what do
i do
and i can lose it now
so it's a terrifying concept like like
power
you know very few of us ever ever get
any kind of influence or power right
once you get it you're like hey what do
i do with this
you know am i going to do it am i going
to do the right things with it and so i
think people withhold themselves because
they don't we're not educated about
money we don't know where it comes from
we have a lot of misinformation about it
our parents terrified us
you know money doesn't grow in trees
uh save your money it'll save you all
these these these things our parents
told us because they were enamored
or encumbered
with the same kind of liabilities around
money right i don't know how to get it
i don't know how to keep it
and
the third the worst part that we're all
at is i don't know how to invest it yeah
so what i'll do is i'll some people get
good at getting it
very few actually fewer people at
keeping it
but probably more than getting it
there's probably a big group in america
that have learned how to keep money
because they're afraid to lose it they
don't want to invest it they don't want
to use it they don't want to you know um
you know kanye talks about this how
white people how white people save all
their money and they just keep it they
just store it like i had an uncle he
buried everything he ever made he went
in the backyard wow
the other uncle was was uh he was he was
a guy that bought he he worked hard very
very frugal
italian descent
and he would uh buy real estate but it
was always buy low and sell high he
actually never sold anything but that
was the concept buy low buy the cheapest
lowest
get everything on a deal if there's food
stamps to be gotten you go get those
food stamps if there's a if there's a
government deal get it if it's section 8
and the government will pay you pay it
so both these guys different kind of
mentalities were extremely frugal
my other uncle
was uh worked in a refinery he basically
saved all his money paid everything off
got out of debt that was their lifestyle
my dad died when i was 10.
so he paid all his debt off had
everything paid and and so that's all i
had right everybody around me was like
get money
keep it keep it don't use it you know
but but you should invest but nobody
ever learns that third one
and and so i think we're just a bunch of
people walking around terrified
of this
this apparent
apparency of it's scarce right
and it's
not and and you know it's not there's
nothing scarce about it you know i'm
always keeping it real with you what has
happened to our country that we make our
idols and our icons and our heroes
rappers and entertainers and ball
players and then we showed disgust
for a businessman that can bank 50
million a year or 20 million a year what
is wrong look when a guy can go out and
make passive investments great decisions
execute show tremendous discipline okay
and disconcert between good investments
and bad investments and then make 20
million or 30 million bucks pay three or
four million dollars in taxes three or
four million dollars to his charities
his churches his community helps out
with groups of people
and and we have discontent for the
businessman that's out there year after
year
making great investments great decisions
showing leadership in the marketplace
look that marketplace out there that
economy is the most savage
most
difficult
playing field in the world to negotiate
yet
who do we admire in our culture rock
stars look these guys got great skills
kid gets out of school makes 12 million
a first year and and we make posters of
them and sweatshirts and and you put
their kids in their jerseys what about
the business people that make our
economy work they pay the taxes that
make the schools work the churches work
to make the the fire department the
police department because they pay taxes
because they're out there making great
investments look admire business people
they're able to bank year after year
admire these people study them learn
from them don't be disgusted with them
and turn off anybody anybody that would
suggest to you that making money in this
country is wrong look don't envy
business people admire them emulate them
learn from them particularly these guys
are doing it year after year after year
not just on income but on wealth
development because that's where you
need to be that's where you need to be
thinking that's the economy you want to
create for yourself your family your
household and your future you know this
concept of time management has been
pushed off on me my entire life and i
have never ever agreed with it i'm like
why would i want to manage time
why would i what am i going to do how do
you manage time what do i do i like okay
i'm going to watch these seconds dude i
don't want to manage time i want to
produce i want to be highly productive i
want to squeeze time i literally want to
take time and i want to turn 60 minutes
into three hours of production that's
the different thing that you need today
not manage time now there are some
tricks when managing time if that's
where you want to come from like alan
greenspan alan greenspan and his
roommate in college his roommate's
father taught alan greenspan a little
trick that alan greenspan used his whole
life and it was to break up the day into
15 minute blocks
15 minutes i have something and then
fill up the next 15 minutes now the
reason alan did that and i like that
concept a lot is because he didn't what
white space on that calendar he knew
white space was a problem because
white space nothing in the 15 minutes is
a waste of time
see before you start thinking about just
managing time first i want you to do
this number one i want you to make a
list of things that you're doing every
day that is a waste of time that is the
way you create time not manage it
the first thing i want to do is look at
things that i'm doing that are wasteful
those two or three hours a day that are
wasteful moments things i'm doing on
facebook that just a waste of time or
maybe a game i'm playing it's a waste of
time or maybe
a newspaper i'm reading where i'm not
really learning anything i'm reading
about the the celebrities it's a waste
of time okay second thing i want you to
do is this i want you to then start
thinking about these 15-minute blocks
and filling that calendar up but the
third and most important thing i want
you to think about is how can you create
time
how can you literally take 24 hours and
and pack more into it so that you can
become more productive so that you can
use that urgency concept and really blow
up your your career blow up your life
make the most incredible life for your
family for you for the kids for your
wife or your husband and for your
clients so that you can take care of
yourself materially as well 12 years ago
we had done maybe i don't know 20
million dollars over the internet
we've done over a billion dollars in
sales over the internet in the last 12
years
okay
thank you
[Music]
like you guys got to learn how to use
enthusiasm like when you use it use it
like the more you use the more you get
you like i'ma save my energy now i don't
want to give him too big a hand too
early
it's really early today come on look man
with somebody successful you ought to
throw down that's what i'm talking about
see
you guys you guys got it y'all got y'all
got to quit trying little tricks and
gimmicks like if you got to walk on fire
to get excited you are ramped up
like like if you can't at will whenever
you want to for any reason just get
excited
then you got a problem okay because in
real in the real world you can't you
can't be in the middle of a meeting and
i'm trying to get her to give me like a
hundred million dollars and i'm not i'm
feeling a little depressed or bad right
now or i got my attention on my kids and
and i'm like okay
[Music]
everybody's gonna be like nah we were
gonna give you 100 until you started
pumping your chest
right you can't say hang on a second man
i got to go into a state change like
that's not real you guys understand you
have to be able to that's a gimmick
and gimmicks take time okay and gimmicks
cannot be duplicated
what can be duplicated are disciplines
and that's what you're going to we're
going to be sharing with you over the
next three days disciplines can be
duplicated if you've seen my children
okay if you've how many of you seen
sabrina and scarlet oh yeah those are
disciplines
okay
if they were in here right now they
could get on that stage and talk to you
they know how to look you and eyes they
know how to shake your hand because they
have been taught how to communicate
we spend less time on teaching them how
to count than we do communicate
connect with people okay we have them
home schooled the home school teacher
what do you want to learn you just keep
teaching them what i'm teaching them
you teach them confidence you teach
employees you teach them the ability to
communicate be dangerous not careful
okay we teach our kids how to be
dangerous
i teach my kids how to meet strangers
and greet strangers we teach our kids
that strangers have everything they want
and strangers are not dangerous
okay is there danger in the society yeah
that's what those guys are for over
there
so i'm going to put my kids an
environment where they can meet 99 of
the people and feel safe to meet them
talk to them communicate with them so i
want to make sure that my kids can walk
into an environment and have
zero concern about him her or him
and they can walk out and say hey i want
to meet you because strangers
have everything that you want
the people you don't know and haven't
met these guys these guys dressed in
their robes what do you call the robes
the condor okay i have one in my closet
by the way i love the condor i put the
condor on one time and i was like i'm a
bad bad man
dude i felt so freaking powerful it was
amazing okay i grew a beard i'm like now
i'm a man
okay give me a camel
okay it was like it was like phenomenal
right like but but you you guys need to
have that kind of swag everywhere in
life and regardless how old you are 25
and you're like i'm too young to have
swag or 55 and now you're too old it's
not true you just need to get the
confidence the bravado not fake it you
don't need to fake it you need to you
need to get you need to get confidence
if i could get rid of this right here in
life if i could get rid of these downs
man how confident would i be
i mean like i'm going into every deal
i'm a win
and that is possible folks okay but it
starts with
who knows
me because if i'm walking around this
planet and nobody knows me i'm going to
be terrified be a better guy man you
know just be a good guy and be be
you know the thing i'm proud of is i get
to be grant all the time you know i'm
actually getting to the point where i'm
like hey man i i finally got to be when
i i finally
became what i wanted to be
what was that me yeah
you know that i don't have to apologize
anymore and then i quit screwing up and
i quit having to call people and say hey
man like i said i went too far you know
if i could just pull some of that back
without that drug that that psychiatrist
was trying to use right you know that if
i'm less dependent upon
aggression you know and i could i could
kind of manifest more you know like you
you talk about better let it flow more
let it flow dude let it flow you know
but
but if i could get that perfect balance
of aggression and flow
that's a sweet spot yeah it's sweet dude
it's hard to find that thing that's a
sweet spot
you know to be that
i don't want to be i want i don't want
to be the little stream that drips you
know i want to be like
but i don't want to damage anybody right
i don't want to hurt anybody you know i
don't want to i don't want to be in
competition anymore mm-hmm but i also
don't want to lose the edge right you
know it's a dance dude it's a dance it's
a dance match you know like like your
girl said to me the other night she's
like
she said something before she left she's
like i really get who you are
you know that and that hits me when
people say that to me most people don't
get who i am um that's beautiful you
know and she said i really get who you
are yeah and and a lot of people don't
yeah and it sometimes it hurts right
because i know who i really am yeah
and
but i also know the things i'm trying to
accomplish for me you know like ryan
ryan gets who i am you know ryan ryan
never takes me on man you're you're the
best grant you're the best
he just he strokes me right right
through it and and and you know my wife
i can see my wife she gets she gets
tired of the the the pounding you know
but hey man i just you know i'm a
right-handed hitter you know or i got i
got a certain ball that i throw a
certain shot i make and yeah it's my
go-to you know and when i get threatened
i'm going to go to that
and now if i could develop some other
set of skills
you know that would be that would be a
cool thing the thing is not to just be
positive
not even to offer this no negativity
policy that i talk about the way to
avoid
uh
negative and distracting people man is
to vibrate at a rate so fast okay that
you're out in front of them once i got a
speeding ticket actually here in miami
and the police officer says
why are you speeding why are you in such
a hurry i'm like dude i'm trying to stay
away from the crazies
okay
if i can just get ahead of everybody
else i'm not distracted by anybody but
guys like you
and your job is to stop me but the truth
is their job is to stop me distract me
and cause me to turn around and and stop
my mission see so i got my ticket and
moved on and went to the head of the
pack again see this is what i'm telling
you man look if you want to not be
bogged down by negative distracted
people
you need to take responsibility that
you're slowing down enough to get caught
up by this magnetic charge of
distractive and negative people do you
need to vibrate so fast that these
people are distracting other people not
you get way ahead of the crowd get so
busy that nobody's gonna jack with you
man because you're filling up your
pipeline you're full you're busy and you
don't have this stuff sticking to you
look if you got negative people around
you if you got distracted people and we
all do
but if it's causing you to be distracted
and negative dude you need to vibrate
you need to fill up your pipeline you
need to explode blow up get busy
so this isn't happening to you because
you're partly responsible fill your
pipeline up success is vital i
absolutely you maybe you've heard me say
this before it's worth writing down
again success is your duty it is your
obligation and your responsibility
success to me is as vital to my survival
as oxygen food and water
shelter i got to have shelter i got to
have water i have to have oxygen i need
food okay i need love in my life okay i
need people i need human interaction and
i also need to win if you don't have
success in your life you will lose
discipline you will lose activity you
will lose contact and you will not be
consistent you will not have them this
is the vital part of success this is why
i'm pounding to you the only trick in
this universe if there is a trick at all
is you must be successful
success is not an option it is your duty
it is your obligation it is your
responsibility 2022 if it's going to be
good for you and your family
if it's going to be great for you and
your family it is because you demand
success this year
and that means you demand success in
your relationships and your finances and
in your money uh your money and in your
business what should you do with your
money well well
like saving money in a bank account it's
ridiculous the only people that benefit
is the bank
so what do you do with the money then
you you you use money first thing people
should invest in is themselves
like you know best thing is people hear
that and they go what does that mean
though what do i do with the money go to
go to workshops go to seminars go to
whatever you're good at whatever you're
doing you're an astronaut invest in
yourself if you're an athlete investing
yourself
don't spend money on belts
yeah and looking good like invest in
your craft you're a comedian invest in
your craft and that means investing in
your skills uh a
coach uh what whatever whatever podcast
yeah whatever needs to get you known
right right and then also in in your
branding and your marketing like people
have to know you no matter how good you
are if i don't know you it doesn't
matter right so you got to get out there
yeah how did you guys run into me how'd
i run into you yeah how did you find out
about it instagram good i invested a lot
of money making sure that people see
that instagram account right right so
our energy money and energy right so uh
invest in yourself first to become great
at whatever you're doing number two
start investing in your business
if that if you hadn't done that already
and the third thing is start investing
in things that will pay you every month
so you bought you buy a flow of income
this idea that it takes money to make
money is not true it's a myth it's it's
it's the number one reason why i did the
show the discovery show to debunk that
on tv
that i didn't need any money at all uh
they they offered me a hundred bucks i'm
like just keep it like no no we got to
give it to you it's part of the show and
i'm like i don't need the hundred
they're like no but you got to take the
hundred as part of the show so the
entire 90 days i never touched the first
hundred they gave me and this was to
prove to people dude you do not need
money like it's just it's not true you
need money you do need contacts
you need people you need you need people
you need people you need the right
people though
the right people that are already in
play
okay just because a guy's got money
i remember a a billionaire friend of
mine uh you know he could buy a jet
and i said hey bob should i buy a jet he
said you should i shouldn't
meaning
grant should because and he's way
wealthier than i am he could have bought
40 of them he's like i don't have a
place to go in mine you have you could
use yours every day
so you've got to find somebody that's in
place somebody that not just has money
but somebody that wants to do more with
their money
so you'll notice in the first 10 days i
don't spend a hun any money i don't
spend money on shelter not on food and
not on water
nothing then what i do is i end up
accumulating assets and it's unfortunate
that the viewer doesn't see this within
five days i have two vehicles one was
given to me by discovery and the other
one was a forty thousand dollar jeep
that i basically used
uh from ryan this guy i met
and told him i'm gonna sell your jeep
i'm gonna drive it around town and put
ten miles a day on it and i'm gonna sell
it well that's a forty three thousand
dollar asset
uh my truck was worth four grand i still
had my hundred dollars i lived in a
forty six thousand dollar rv
that i was trying to sell
so yeah uh and then what what's the
other thing i did and i picked up ten
thousand dollars
to do in a 15 partnership in the equity
of the upside of this guy's company so
literally in 10 days
i was accumulating contacts that could
get me equity and the important part of
that story is man go get you some equity
you know jay-z talks about this you're
getting you know so many of you young
brothers are getting in advance while
i'm picking up the equity showing up
means
showing up it don't mean you got to the
office
you understand it doesn't mean you came
to work
[Music]
for me showing up means i show up i've
been showing up since i was
25 years old man before that i wasn't
showing up
i was showing off
i was acting a fool being a fool
high school i didn't show up i went to
class i never showed up
my body went in the room
see showing up doesn't mean you got
there showing up means you got there and
then you showed up again and then you
showed up again and you showed up again
it means you show up for the class you
show up for the homework you show up for
the class you show up for the homework
you show up for the test you freaking
get a perfect grade means you keep
showing up to the next level
and i hear a lot of people talking about
showing up you know showing up's not
everything let me tell you something
showing up when you show up the right
way
johnny you got to put your seatbelt on
when you show up the right way
showing up is 100 of success showing up
means you're looking for deeper levels
to show up to pay attention
that's what i do every day every day i
come to work i'm like show up man show
up for every little problem show up for
every little opportunity show up for
every little little new nuance
little angle little particle little
movement that's why i see all this stuff
why is that not cleaned up why is this
not cleaned up what's it why don't
somebody pick that up who's that new
person here
hey you feeling all right today how many
times have i asked you that before you
all right today i know it's little
things
it's simple it costs nothing to do this
show up
it costs you
nothing and it makes all the difference
man showing up
you'll see things that no one else sees
and and you know the good news is
anybody can do this you just got to make
a commitment to show up the reason the
guys on wall street and the gals on wall
street make so much money
okay it's not because they're they're
they're like capitalists and they're
terrible people it's because they're
surrounded by people that are making
money man they're accountable by their
stock price they're accountable to their
production they got people around them
that expect them to win and do well and
also they're going to dinner waking up
at breakfast working out in the gym with
other people that are winning big in
life okay so you need feedback from your
environment and your network fourth
thing you need is you got to have fifth
thing you need is you got to have a
network of people that are encouraging
you
to kill it you got to have the right net
you got to have a lebron in your game
man if you're playing in the nba and
lebron's like i'm gonna take you under
my wing bro
[__]
okay kobe's like hey man i wanna i'm
coming back to be with you man what
would you deny that okay michael jordan
i wanna be with you man tiger woods i
wanna golf with you come on guys what
are you doing you cannot do this alone
you cannot do this alone are you kidding
me man let's say you want to be a
surgeon and a top surgeon in the world's
like i want to take you under my wing
what are you going to be i'm too busy
what are you willing to give up you guys
got to keep assessing the situation and
not be
broad stroke about it and say oh i'm not
going to be a diletta or i'm going to be
a professional i'm going to i'm not
going to no no but what are you going to
give up
there are times though again when i will
that agreement
see like one of the things i have on
here being right you have to give up
being right
you know you can't can't want to be be
right and be successful they don't even
go together
it's impossible so again i'm willing to
give the up being right just kind of
don't quit man if you don't quit if you
don't quit you can't fail
it's impossible failure becomes
impossible for those who don't quit
it's impossible just think about it if i
keep moving towards the destination
if i if i'm if i'm going through the
alphabet
a b c d e dude if you just keep going
all the way to z you finish the alphabet
you break your leg along the way
somebody cut your tongue out you get
waterboarded
you get a divorce you lose your dad you
lose a puppy
if you get the z you finish the alphabet
period and boy when i heard that i'm
like goddamn what was i thinking i was
thinking i could fail i can't fail if i
don't quit
so so that means i got to get rid i got
to dump people out of the car though
along the way right but we had to get
rid of a whole bunch of people
i i have to get rid of people how many
people have been have gone johnny
huh i mean guys like if you saw the
wreckage
like
so much you don't see it you know oh i'm
not saying get rid of people i'm just
saying like like like what are you
willing to give up
okay on my list i've given up a house
i've given up money i gave up my
retirement accounts i had millions of
dollars sitting in retirement accounts i
paid the penalty to get the money
because it was a mistake years ago i got
convinced by the banks to build an ira
or a 401k because i was trying to figure
out how to exit actually the people that
were giving me the advice were telling
me to figure out how to exit
you're planning an exit when you're 30
and it's stupid
think about what you're doing you're not
going to retire until you're 70
and the rich people never
worry about their retirement accounts
warren buffett has not got a 401k
he's got coca-cola
see the difference
see the difference in the think
okay
so so like like you you guys have to
take a look at what you know
that is now a liability
what you know to be true
that has become a liability for you
and if you just study the middle class
of america study the entire structure of
the american economy
you will see
you will see where a lot of these
liabilities exist that that are or are
core values that you have
not just for you but for the entire
population of people
[Music]
and and like if you just look at the
structure of america 311 million people
most of them are not doing well
you hear about it every day so the
solution is let's give everybody college
you know
let's give everybody well college could
be one of the problems
look
you know let's make sure everybody gets
through high school okay
could be one of the problems actually
that it takes 12 years to learn how to
count
[Music]
and still no product
really
so anyway i'm not saying i'm not worried
about trying to change all that i'm just
saying you might want to look at how
some of that has influenced you
you know the retirement accounts the
life insurance how many of you got life
insurance
how many of you got some cash value
sitting there somehow
dude get the money
don't wait till you that one thing that
i've done since i was 25 years old
is learn how to set goals put them in
place and then manifest them over
periods of time in my lifetime if you go
back and listen to the rules of success
that i shot that show and i think i was
4 35 years old 36 years old in la jolla
california i was living on the ocean
then and
you can go back to that you can look in
the 10x rule when i wrote the 10x rule i
shared a bunch of goals that was 11
years ago you can see over the last 25
years every single goal that i have set
for myself up to this point anyway i
have been able to achieve my wife my two
beautiful kids the condition that my
body's in today my finances the real
estate all of it started with goals all
of it started with the idea that was in
my mind and had not yet been manifested
in reality
i heard a saying once uh barbara
streisand said that there was not one
thing in her career that she had
accomplished tips on writing goals
number one write them down every day in
fact what i do is i write mine down on a
blank sheet of paper
i write them down in the am i write them
down in the pm
and i also write them down anytime i'm
disappointed or discouraged
okay so i could actually write my goals
down more than twice a day always in the
am always in the pm first thing i do in
the morning first thing i did today was
i wrote my goals down second thing what
i'll do before i go to sleep tonight is
write my goals down it could be on the
same legal pad second thing i write them
down in present tense
in pt
present tense or even past tense
or past okay so i may write it as though
i have accomplished it what you don't
want to do is
uh write it down
one day i will love my job okay you want
to write down i love my job even if you
hate your job right now just like flip
it i love my job okay i love my wife and
kids i didn't have a wife and kids
uh my kids loved me i didn't have any
children okay i wrote it down as though
it was happening
okay um
write your goals down
whether or not you're achieving them or
not it doesn't matter that you're
achieving them okay this is going to
sound a bit like you're deceiving
yourself
which is what you're doing you're
writing down the future as though it's
happening today and or has happened
number four strongly suggest that you go
ten times bigger on your goals than you
think what is accomplishable okay i say
go big or
go bigger baby
okay go big or go bigger there is
nothing wrong with big think
it doesn't cost anything okay you can't
get taxed for thinking big
and it's not just
okay i'm a dream big and big things are
gonna happen okay i am going to
uh write down hey i'm trying to achieve
x in my life i'm trying to go from here
to 10 times bigger than i can think
okay during the day i'm going to take
the actions that support that when i
write this down every day number five do
not be disappointed
in not achieving just keep writing
just because you're not hitting it just
keep writing it
i wrote down off and on from time to
time i wrote down for years my dad
worked his ass off and when he died
he did good my mom had to sell
everything
and so i'm like okay that didn't work
but he was considered successful the
middle class successful briefcase good
job professional people respected him
saved his money had life insurance house
was paid for everything by the book
and she was unloading stuff the next
week because she was terrified and so
from the age of 10 to like
16 17 years old [__] we were just scared
dude clipping coupons
buying everything on sale
single mother everywhere she goes she
knows they're gonna rip her off the
plumber the roofer the car dealer
everybody's gonna rip her off right so
she thought save your money save for a
rainy day yeah you know penny saved is
right a penny earned it's not it's a
[__] penny yeah right it's a [__]
penny yeah i mean it's a penny dude yeah
you won't even pick a penny up today you
ain't with a penny dude
you know 50 cent come on man
that's 50 pennies
the third thing i would say about
wealthy people is there
i mean different people have different
ways they invest but they tend to be
more
focused on the long-term appreciation of
an asset
rather than give me money this second
and and i think to get there they're not
stuck in this get-rich-quick thing it's
a delayed gratification yeah they're
more like yeah i'd rather have wealth
tomorrow than rich today
and they do have a distinction between
the rich and the wealthy the you know
the super wealthy are looking to create
wealth beyond their own
means and needs like they're not
thinking about their kids their boat
their plane i know people think that but
that's not actually true they're
actually thinking about how do i create
wealth for a lot of people amazon's got
a million employees
yeah now most of them only earn minimum
wage but there's some people at the
upper level of amazon that are making
fortunes you're reading a book
okay you're listening to music
going to an event
uh
speaking at an event
let's say you're speaking in a minute is
the 700th time you did that presentation
you got to show up new again
johnny comes to work with his camera
we're doing a show today johnny needs to
show up new looking for new angles new
colors new
you got to show up every day new folks
you're new man you're new
ladies and gentlemen you're new
every day you're new or
guess what you're old
nobody wants old
i don't want to get old
i don't want stale
i don't want yesterday's
i don't want leftovers
i don't i don't i know i know when
somebody's repeating something wrote
they're just giving me the same
i don't mind some [__] but it's got
to be fresh i need some fresh [__]
so i don't i don't mind a little bit of
[__] i just don't want the same
thing
okay that guy's told that story a
thousand times and it looks like the
thousand thousand times not in a good
way either last thing i'm gonna tell you
is this
okay
don't
get
stuck in mechanics
when i'm writing my goals down i do not
know how i'm going to do it
so i merely sit down like i remember for
years i would write down i own a
helicopter i don't even know where this
concept came from i own a helicopter i
own a helicopter i own a helicopter
every once in a while it would show up
it would show up on a wednesday and not
show up for uh when i'm writing my goals
down right so i'm waking up in the
morning i wake up in the morning i write
my goals down and one day i write i own
a helicopter
i think back then it was a i learned how
to fly a helicopter
okay it was stupid it was completely
ridiculous i'm like where'd that come
from
it just kind of floated into my mind i
wrote it down okay i own a jet
i'm like man i'm just being stupid right
now i own a jet and two helicopters
i don't know how that happened i didn't
i didn't know anything about jets uh i
would not achieve any of this by the way
until i was
53 years old 54 years old
the first private jet i was ever on was
the one
we bought
i didn't know anything about it i didn't
know how they fly i didn't know how they
work i didn't know what the cost of a
hangar was i know nothing don't get lost
in the mechanics i didn't know the fuel
cost i didn't know what it cost to buy
one do you finance them do you pay cash
do you get a tax rate i knew nothing
when i started writing this down the
helicopter would come after the jet okay
i bought a helicopter i didn't know why
so the point of that story is when
you're writing your goals down literally
sit down with a blank sheet of paper
first thing you wake up in the morning
and you just start zip zip zip zip zip
you right through them like this morning
i wrote down 40 billion in real estate
okay public i write down one word i'm
going public
see i know now that this this is in
present tense and or past tense i write
it in present or past tense i'm going
public okay i wrote down recently uh a
congressional hearing
people like what's a congressional
hearing dude i'm so big now they called
me into congress
they're going to have a congressional
hearing they're going to drill me
okay oh yeah then i wrote this down a
political office
now i don't know why
i don't know why i'm writing that down i
don't know how to achieve that i don't
know what it would mean i don't know
what it looks like i don't get stuck in
the mechanics don't worry about it
commit first man just keep committing it
keep fueling and keep writing it down 8
billion people
know my name
the only thing i can control my life are
the things that i'm willing to take
responsibility for these gladiators that
came here thousands of years ago and
maybe lost their lives if they took
responsibility for the match full
responsibility and i might be taking
this too far right now i don't know i
don't know what it was like to be a
gladiator in 720 740 a.d okay i can't
even imagine fighting in front of 50 000
people with lions possibly coming out to
eat me okay but i know this you really
got to get this point carried away you
got to get it like in your head you're
an executive you're a business owner
you're a manager you're trying to hire
people you're trying to hire people and
you're like oh the people are bad
everybody's terrible everybody's bad i
can't find good people to take
responsibility we all have something to
do with what's going on around us
you and i authorized others
to drop the bomb look i've been robbed
twice in my life 23 years old i was
almost killed guy came in my house put a
45-caliber pistol in my face hit me
right here then put 70 stitches in my
head and face robbed me
in new orleans louisiana i was robbed
at a younger age
i caused both of those i was the victim
in both situations on the police report
victim
robbed by
criminals truth is i wasn't a victim i
created both of those wrong place wrong
time wrong people i had something to do
with that
everything that happens to you is
because of you
quit passing it off
right it's going to rain on me right now
while i'm shooting this
dude that's my fault i could have shot
this thing yesterday when it was
sunshine
watch and read high-performance people
and you will see that they always take
responsibility when their life goes to
to garbage it's when they quit taking
responsibility the greats in the world
keep track of everything when they're in
the game
when they're the gladiator when they're
the ball player when they're the
executive of a big company they're
statizing everything okay how many
outbound how many inbound uh what's our
closing ratio what's our right ratio
everything is measured measure your
actions and measure your results those
that don't and won't are irresponsible
and they
will cause you problems
i remember as a young salesperson i was
keeping a log not on what i sold but on
what i said to people i kept everything
how many people i talked to how many
people i waited on how many people i
wrote up how many people i negotiated
with how many people i closed how many
people i talked to on the phone and also
what they said and what i said what
worked and what didn't work i was taking
responsibility this is the only way you
can take responsibility by the way
you can't just say oh i'm responsible
you got to do something to follow up the
responsibility
it's how i handle
and learned and became a professional
salesperson i handle the future by
handling by being responsible for the
present
you go in that gladiator you go in there
as a gladiator in that coliseum okay and
you don't figure out how you lost that
last fight you're gonna die on the next
one take responsibility even if the
other guy cheated
he surprised you he shocked you he
pulled out some other weapon you didn't
know about be prepared for the future by
taking responsibility for the president
so be responsible be the cause not the
effect be responsible
even when you're not responsible be
responsible bad things happen to good
people good things by the way happen to
good people and blame no one be
responsible and remember this you want
to be great you want to be super
successful take responsibility for
everything
even the things that you could have no
responsibility for i've been a sales guy
for a long time and i i just learned
early on
and i was terrible at sales 17 years old
18 19 part-time part-time sales guy was
i was awful
when i finally realized that sales was
the only job i could get at 25 years old
i'm just like dude i just got to tell
people the truth because i can't do all
these tricks
the nlp
the and look if it works for you good
whatever but the mirroring the matching
they ask a question you ask a question
the hot potato i've heard all these
strategies and i'm like dude i just
can't do it i'm just going to be me hey
guys i'm i'm moving from la i'm out of
work i'm looking for opportunity i'm
trying to move my family here my name's
louis curtis
uh 2008 beat me up i got to get my
family out of la real estate's
impossible i can't buy it there it's out
priced out of the market and i'm here in
pueblo
because i think there's opportunity here
and that's all i'm looking for no
handouts no help i don't i got an old
truck with me i got no money i left my
kids with you got to have your story
this is what you got to do to play the
game one you got to be committed
you got to be like hey i need to learn
about real estate you can't do real
estate bitcoin stocks like you can't do
everything and be great at one thing
you just be a half-assed player at all
everything
and you'll never go hard enough on one
thing to ever make you any big money you
know what i'm saying i mean if you're
going to play the crypto thing then you
need to know which crypto's going to win
they're not all gonna win
and then you need to go hard and heavy
on that one thing real estate
for 30 years i've been studying the real
estate game and i mean i just
i know this game now
i got the eye
i'm looking for their barriers to entry
i'm looking for scarcity i'm looking for
irreplaceable
and i'm looking for something where i
can value add add value to the property
without spending a lot of money i'm
gonna probably spend 150 000 on the
landscaping of this pool
that could be worth five large to me
that's a 40 35 x return
i got to be able to pay for it
i got to be able to see it
i got to be able to commit to it but how
are you going to see the deal if you're
looking at everything you're not
so i'm on the ocean in miami
i know the best property in miami's got
sand in front
there's plenty of condos there's nothing
you can really do with a condo the only
thing you do with a condo is get a good
price on it
and hope to sell it hope to sell it for
something later on a property like this
you could actually overpay for a
property like this if you got the i the
i or the real estate invested rei
so look if you want to learn oh look at
that pelicans flying overhead man
beautiful
if you want to learn the game the way i
know it this is a simple simple game
okay
available to men women black brown white
hispan you name it it doesn't matter who
you are where you are it doesn't matter
what your religion or education is
okay it doesn't even matter if you got a
credit score
seriously or money down you got to know
what you're looking for because if you
find the right deal
you can find money for it because you
made it this far in a video i want to
celebrate you most people start and
don't finish most people never actually
follow through most people say they want
something but they don't ever do the
work to actually get it but you're
different you're special believe nation
you made it here all the way to the end
and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for even
more grant cardone motivation check the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there there was somebody
saying look the more more oil companies
we have the better because it's good for
the customer
right
the more technology companies we have
it's not just microsoft
the better for the customer